[Music]
alphago has been through many
generations now the first generation of
alphago which we published in our
original nature paper was able to beat a
professional player for the first time
now we have the final version of alphago
alphago zero which has learned
completely from scratch from first
principles without using any human data
and has achieved the highest level of
performance overall the most important
idea in alphago zero is that it learns
completely tabula rasa that means it
starts completely from a blank slate and
figures out for itself only from self
play and without any human knowledge
without any human data without any human
examples or features or intervention
from humans it discovers how to play the
game of Go completely from first
principles so tabula rasa learning is
extremely important to our goals and
ambitions that deep mind and the reason
is that if you can achieve tabula rasa
learning you really have an agent that
can be transplanted from the game of go
to any other domain you untie yourself
from the specifics of the domain you're
in and you come up with an algorithm
which is so general that it can be
applied anywhere for us the idea of
alphago is not to go out and defeat
humans but actually to discover what it
means to to do science and for a program
to be able to learn for itself what
knowledge is so what we starts to see
was that alphago zero not only
rediscovered the common patterns and
openings that humans tend to play these
joseki patterns that humans play in the
corners it also learned them discovered
them and ultimately discarded them in
preference for its own variants which
humans don't even know about or play at
the moment and so we can say that really
what's happened is that in a short space
of time
alphago zero has understood all of the
go knowledge that has been accumulated
by humans over thousands of years of
playing and it's analyzed it and it
started to look at it and discover much
of this knowledge for itself and
sometimes it's chosen to actually go
beyond that and come up with something
which the humans hadn't even discovered
in this time period
and developed new pieces of knowledge
which were creative and and
novel in many ways we're all really
excited by how far alpha go zero has
cotton but I think what we're most
excited about is how far it can go in
the real world that the fact that we've
seen a program can achieve a very high
level of performance in domain as
complicated and challenging as go should
mean that now we can start to tackle
some of the most challenging and
impactful problems for Humanity